j'étais désespéré martin vient dans son
jardin pour y trouver un peu de calme
c'est frustrant c'est cet argent à peine
remis d'une dépression il est sans
emploi depuis cet hiver les derniers
mois ont été particulièrement stressant
j'ai perdu mon emploi moi le défi de
l'année passée j'ai fait une demande
auprès de l'assurance emploi chamas
essien ont plus de six mois après avoir
rempli sa demande il n'a toujours pas
reçu un sou de l'assurance emploi à tous
les vendredis réseau plaît parce que je
me disais que théoriquement le jeudi
d'avoir de quoi dans mon corps je
finissais l'appelle le piège du centre
bourg y est pas ce que fait avancer peau
du chef comment faire pour mes sorties
des lions service com de chômeurs dans
cet organisme de défense des chômeurs il
on voit de toutes les couleurs ces jours
ci son parle de d'hélène ministre hâtif
c'est un chaos une soeur de marat cela
l'assurance emploi pierre séré évolue
dans le domaine depuis près de 40 ans
les délais pour traiter une demande
d'assurance emploi n'ont jamais été
aussi long ça toujours fait partie dans
les retards la bureaucratie c'est
compliqué on comprends pas pourquoi
certains mais là ça prend des
proportions qui sont extravagantes on
est un peu dans une situation qui est
extrême ya moins de prestataires
d'assurance emploi est à la fois le
système est embourbé à la famille près
de 22000 canadiens attendaient depuis
plus de trois mois un premier versement
selon des données obtenues par le bloc
québécois en vertu d'une demande d'accès
à l'information on a atteint des
situations d'emploi qui s'apparente à du
plein emploi
difficile de dire exactement ce qui
concer délai avant c'était des
formations en personne qui ait les
employés peuvent avoir avec 80 % des
fonctionnaires de l'assurance-emploi en
télétravail le syndicat montre du doigt
des problèmes de formation
d'apprentissage et des problèmes
informatiques en ces points problème de
nombre d'employés sujet mais se trouve
passé on n'a jamais eu autant d'employés
commandes en ce moment service canada un
pays pourtant on est
je pense qu'on a rarement été aussi
inefficace
je me pose des questions savoir comment
est ce que je fais pour payer mon loyer
payé mon épicerie
j'avais la chance car milow d'avoir un
peu d'économie geslot d'aimer cars 2 qui
avait aussi
c'est comme si on les assure vivre avec
deux enfants en bas âge martin et sa
conjointe parviennent à joindre les deux
bouts mais de peine et de misère la
situation au québec en particulier
le résultat d'une dune fraude d'identité
à dans le secteur
la ministre fait valoir que des vols
d'identité ont ralenti le processus
et des cas plus complexes demande des
vérifications
natori pendant ce temps martin n'a
toujours reçu aucune prestation service
canada lui a assuré que ce n'était
qu'une question de jours mais se trouver
un nouvel emploi la semaine passée j'ai
commencé je touche du bois là ça va bien
puis j'ai pas l'intention de l'or ce
soit pour retourner à voir mes amis de
l'assurance emploi ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada saint-hyacinthe